Guido Segal, Screenwriter, Journalist, Film
Critic, Instructor: Great ideas don't make
great movies they can help but great movies
need events and conflict and characters.
Film Courage: What's your writing process?
Guido: My writing process it starts off with
procrastination and I've got to say this because
every writer does it and it's terrible I don't
recommend it but no let's be honest writing
starts off with an idea right and you get excited
about this idea and you have to write it down
again I'm talking about writing on spec it's very
different if you're coming in to write something
or you know if there's a pre-existing let's
start off with writing on spec and I'll answer
the question separately if you know about
writing based on someone else's material so
if it's my own script there's an idea
and I'm very excited about it and I need
to write it down and I need to capture it as
best as I can right so I usually might be on
my computer or might be just hand written right
and I'll take a notebook and I'll start writing
and of course I'm very satisfied with that but
then you realize okay this idea is not the story
right everyone has a great idea but then you have
to break down break it down into characters and
beats and it's so much more complex and of course
it will change because I’d great ideas don't make
great movies they can help but great movies need
events right and conflict and characters and so on
so you start breaking at some point you start
breaking down a story you get very frustrated
because now it's real right ideas are up
there flying in the air but then you're
breaking it down and now it's got it's
gotten real so you start breaking it down
and you explore characters separately and if some
people do backstory I discover backstory as I go
along some people start off from theme I love
theme by the way it's something I think about
I tend to I think of theme as a question you know
some people some people will use words right like
love full potential right I don't know what
to do with with those words and you know
in terms of practical writing
like it's a story about love
sure I mean but what do I do with that so
to me themes are more more of a question
more of a specific question you know it might
be a movie about sports but then the theme is
how does it feel like to not be recognized by your
father right for example so I mean it's something
I can relate to and then I can explore and the
story is an answer to that question in a way
so once I have the idea I start breaking
down separately character and backstory
the world right if it's period I have to do
research and I love research I actually love
it so much that I would spend my entire life just
doing research I love going reading books watching
movies going to library you know sometimes great
the new york public library has an amazing archive
and you go there in the back with your little
gloves and then you just spend hours going through
original letters and I had a blast doing that
so research not too much because at some point
it can drive you mad so at some point
you got to stop with research and start
making things up and once you have like the
world the characters the beats and now you're
ready to start writing if it's you know if
it's based on someone else's material then
well I guess instead of coming up with the beats
you're trying to find those beats in the book or
the source material and the characters the beauty
of adaptations is the characters are a given
you know still it doesn't mean that you're going
to take everything in there you got to learn what
to take and what to discard of course a friend
who's a producer the other day was telling me that
movies are not novels movies are short stories and
and short films are like poems so you know there's
not a lot of beats in a movie even if you're doing
a three-hour long movie there's not an infinite
amount of beats novels have so much material
that you got to weed out what stays and what goes
so it might seem like you have a lot of you know
real estate to to develop your story but you don't
an average 100 minute movie is
i'd say about 36 to 40 beats
maybe maybe more if it's really fast-paced
but you only have a certain amount of scenes
in a 90-minute script you know you have
33-minute scenes again it's not math
but you know what I'm saying is you really
I've got to pick what you're gonna focus on
it doesn't matter if it's an adaptation or your
own work for your script regarding Timothy Leary
since he had such a vast long life I'm not sure
when he passed away he took his life correct he
died yeah in the late 90s he was already in his
80s okay sure how did you know what you what time
period or did you cover most of it well actually
it took me several drafts to figure that out
I knew it had to start in the 60s the first
draft I wrote the script started in 1963
which is when he gets kicked out of Harvard
because he gave students psilocybin and LSD
but then I realized I had to go back I had
to start it off in 1960 which is when he gets
hired at Harvard because it's he's 40 years old
he's going through a middle age crisis his wife
first wife has just committed suicide recently
no one knows about this so I figured you know
I got to start at the beginning and sometimes
it's not easy to know where the beginning is
it's really up to you so I actually wrote I
think like two drafts that took place in 63
then I went back to 1960 which is the current
version and then the beauty of it is you can
have at least five or six seasons if you
wanted because every stage of his life
is a different whole different thing Harvard
California New York Afghanistan Switzerland yeah
but only I mean I wrote the first draft based
on the book and then I went to the public
library in New York where there
are approximately 463 I think boxes
of his belongings wow his personal archive and I
you know I rifled through that and I didn't get to
all the boxes by the way because that's insanity
I did go through a lot of them over several trips
and you know it was there's nothing
I like better than spending time with
you know studying original sources right
and then he had a subsequent relationship
with someone that he cared very deeply for didn't
he but it's debatable whether she was hired
to spy on him oh there was a documentary that
came out recently by Errol Morris I think it's
his fourth wife Joanna Harcourt Smith Larry had
several wives well there was a whole debate I
had with the producer who was who's a friend of
mine and who was convinced that leer was a saint
and I had to tell him no he was this man
was incredibly flawed very responsible
we I think he's our way into the counter
culture and telling that whole story
I don't think we should use this
man as an example of anything
because he for for decades he talked about the
death of ego and he had nothing but ego actually
he was married to I think five amazing women and
he disrespected all of them and he could never
you know he could never love them the way they
loved him and it's actually tragic I know I mean
I hope none of the fans Larry's fans are listening
because they're going to kill me but I think he's
a very contradictory man very you know he had
the he had the charm he could lure people in
very smart but I think the the the one in that
relationship the one who actually transcended
all that was Richard Alpert who became Ram
Dass so in the show we have Leary who's who's
a voice of this whole movement but in a way
I feel like he's disingenuous and you have
Ram Dass who actually did go to India and
transcend ego and became this beautiful being.
What do you think makes a good movie?